salut je crois que ça fait longtemps
qu'on n'a pas fait de mentalisme du
moins un tour de mentalisme sur cette
chaîne et c'est ce qui va se passer
aujourd'hui mais attention à la fin de
cette vidéo j'ai une annonce pas piquée
des hannetons comme dirait monsieur mix
m
je pense que c'est la plus grosse
annonce que j'ai jamais faite sur cette
chaîne alors je compte sur vous pour
aller savoir si vous regardez pas la
vidéo en entier au moins aller voir la
fin quoi bref environ une fois par mois
je vais recevoir un but tu as une ue
buzz ou quelqu'un que j'aime bien ici
dans ce petit local
hélas cette semaine on envoie du lourd
avec monsieur à venir la vidéo que vous
allez voir elle s'est passé en deux
temps dans un premier temps il m'a
demandé de faire quelque chose qui l'a
filmé lui pour mettre sur sa chaîne et
m'a dit est ce que tu es capable de
faire si ça ça je fais ok je sais pas je
vais essayer et bien j'ai bien galéré
alors mes temps qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer
écoutez bien moi je vais vous le dire
qui va se passer je vous laisse tout de
suite avec la vidéo et on se retrouve à
la fin on vient de tourner une vidéo sur
sa chaîne on fait un truc de mentalisme
je cherche à retrouver un prêt d'un an
qu'il pensait qu'ils étaient sept
personnes pour lui et autant vous dire
que j'ai galéré
si tu veux me voir me planter vas voir
je te mets un lien dans la description
voir un mec supérieurement intelligent
on va voir dans la description c'est ça
l'avenir et le contentieux chez le
prétentieux
quand même pas garer mais c'est parce
que j'étais fait gagner oui mais bon
même dû parfois on essaie de marier les
rangs n'y arrive pas enfin bref vous
allez comprendre maintenant pourquoi je
suis un peu plus fragiles maintenant il
ya un petit côté ps qui reste on va
faire un truc en deux temps quelque
chose sur lequel vous allez pouvoir
essayer de participer si vous voulez et
quelque chose
vous pourrez aussi essayé mais qui sera
un peu plus compliqué de faire choisir
un mode alors ça c'est un bouquin que
j'ai eues dans le train de jours à la
rochelle mais il a le mérite d'avoir des
maux de dents la bête noire tu prends un
mot de dans n'importe quoi prends un mot
quand même de qu'un peu d'intérêt pas un
mot trop court comme bien le rire les
gens on va dire au moins trois syllabes
que ce soit intéressant
moi je vais même sortir comme ça il n'y
a pas d'ambiguïté
il est bon une fois que c'est fait tu
l'écris sur un des trois papiers
d'accord c'est bon t'as maintient un mot
un peu long et où coule mais au moins
voilà au moins trois syllabes quoi
disant ouais ouais ouais comme cheminée
obama était tellement rapide
ok on peut être sûr que j'écrive un
bulldozer alors je vais sortir je sors
dehors ou là bas où je me mets la dans
un coin ce que tu veux tu vois pour
refus devront tourner parce que j'ai
noté ça marche tu la quittes aide un peu
parce que tu galères et à leurs
responsables
si je fais sur un des papiers mais tu
écris aussi un mot qui n'a rien à voir
genre raté ou c'est pas ça sur les
autres papiers tu voies d'accès à la fin
des trois papiers au moins un truc
découvre ça marche
ok je vais me lit ok alors vous allez
forcément une coupe dans la vidéo ce
serait trop long sinon mais rassurez
vous je suis resté comme ça il y 2 il na
pas boucher n'a point au chiffre
conjoint m est ce que tu peux les mettre
en ligne tous les trois s'il te plaît
vous allez essayer de participer aussi à
ça en même temps avec la coupe vous
n'avez pas forcément pu voir sur quoi à
venir avait marqué sont donc mais moi je
sais plus google c'est vrai si vos
petits sachets vérifier un tueur
c'est bon c'est bon ok ça finit mélanger
un petit peu maintenant il fait poser
des questions et moi à l'oreille je vais
essayer d'avoir la bonne réponse et vous
vous allez essayer de le faire mais en
plus vous avez comme avantage de voir à
venir est ce que tu peux me dire la
phrase suivante très sincèrement
d'accord j'ai écrit mon mot sur le
triangle
j'ai écrit mon mot sur le triangle est
ce que tu peux faire pareil avec le
cercle mais j'ai écrit mon nous sur le
cercle
ok est ce que tu peux y apparaît avec
les vagues j'ai écrit mon nom sur les
vagues
ok geste et tu peux me dire dans quel
ordre ils sont là les trois papiers de
gauche à droite
certes le redire mais maintenant dans le
sens inverse donc vague xtag je voulais
la phrase ou non non tu ma madrague
cercle triangle ok je pense que tu es
kitambo sur les vagues est ce que c'est
correct
c'est ça bravo oui ok ça c'était plus
simple pour moi ça va lui ce grand
respect de la confiance mais là je te
demander s'il te plaît de me mentir pour
l'instant en main en me disant la
première lettre mais tu n'y vas la vraie
première
[Musique]
tu lis notre hockey est ce que tu peux
faire une phrase complète la première
latte et l'ol la première lettre de l
alors là je vais en avoir besoin mais
c'est la seule fois je te demanderai
c'est c'est vraiment pour pouvoir
calibre et des mentions de la vérité
maintenant tu vas me dire la première
lettre et le études il a brûlé la
première lettre et de s ok et redit
encore avec un mensonge
la première lettre
la première lettre est notée je vais
essayer d'avoir la lettre suivante
mais ce coup ci c'est toi qui vas dire
l'alphabet le public possible qu'il y
avait cédé mgh excita d'accord a b c d e
f g h et l âme noter que le reste est ok
ça a déconné vers une autre planète
était passé c'était oui juste un message
à droite je suis retourné je dis oui je
m'en suis rendu compte [ __ ] j'ai buggé
sûreté plutôt à la bonté de tir
bravo bravo ok après deux concernent pas
forcément une voyelle tu vas me dire ah
oui on y associe pout y encore une fois
le hip hop y ok oui ok on refait un coup
toutes les lettres de l'alphabet tu
penses à la lettre suivante a b c d e f
g h i j k l n au pq est un ex aequo avec
ouais c'est ça mais j'ai voulu tromper
en deux ans avant et j'ai parlé du coup
je dire je fonce après leurs stocks
reding sur la fin stupéfiant stupéfiants
tous types et factuel a lu le livre
oui j'ai lu voilà c'est ça ouais bravo
stupéfiants de stupéfiants bon ça va
stupéfiante franchement lier l'âge du
coup aussi dans les vagues
j'ai failli tromper [ __ ] t'es là écrit
en petit mais en moi je me suis pas
retournée comme ça par transparence je
pouvais peur nous avions aussi sucette
sais pas pourquoi je me suis dit que les
surprises
un truc et qui est peut-être bon écoute
moi je me dis surprise 6 est stupéfiant
j'arrête à dire on en sait beaucoup plus
sur toi mec m'a fait qualité mais
franchement là tu vois
et sur la dernière sur le péché je sais
pas comment tu fais c'est là où tu fais
du contrôle je pense c'est que tu sais
que maintenant je vais voir exactement
de boîte et ça et que j'aime bien ta
mémoire droit 34e lettre on va essayer
d'avoir je vais essayer de l'avoir et en
fait c'est vraiment chapeau de cela
c'est très fort ces gènes
cool alors là l'idée c'était vraiment de
faire un double format vous pouviez
essayé de faire des choses en même temps
en envoyant plus que moi aussi ce genre
d'idée vous plaît vous le dites dans les
commentaires comme ça j'en ferai
d'autres un peu construit la même
manière et puis si ça vous a plu surtout
on n'oublie pas on met des petits like
je ne sais toujours pas pourquoi je
prendre des voies différentes à chaque
fois je vous invite également à checker
aussi la chaîne de notre pote à venir si
vous voulez voir en même temps la vidéo
de mon 2 fail c'est plutôt rigolo et je
vous mets évidemment le lien en
descriptions alors c'est quoi cette
grande annonce où nous a saoulé pour
rester jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo non
c'est une vraie bête d'annoncer un peu
l'annnonce de l'univers pour moi dans ma
tête depuis le mois de mars je travaille
sur un projet secret les projets se crée
de fabien un truc qui me motive de ouf
mais je savais pas si je serai capable
de mettre en place ou pas ça rapport
avec le monde du spectacle pour que vous
puissiez comprendre l'ampleur de la
chose j'ai commencé le théâtre à paris
en 2011 dans un café théâtre qui
s'appelle les trois bornes un petit café
théâtre de 49 places dans le 11e et
quand j'ai fait ça j'étais en
autoproduction c'est à dire je me gère
tout seul j'ai pas de producteurs qui
s'occupent de moi de choses comme ça et
là on est six ans plus tard et toujours
en autoproduction je viens de caler une
date de mon spectacle mon nouveau
spectacle tout seul en entier dans un
petit lieu parisien qui s'appelle
l'olympia et règne de le dire j'ai un
feu d'artifice là dedans
alors voilà c'est rien de le dire mais
c'est beaucoup d'excitation et beaucoup
de stress en même temps puisque comme
c'est une autoproduction je prend tous
les risques que j'ai signé le contrat
j'ai loué l'olympia et je vais faire mon
spectacle là bas reste à savoir quand
vous voulez la date est bien la date
c'est dans un an jour pour jour c'est le
22 septembre 2018 alors ça paraît loin
mais c'est juste ce qu'il faut pour bien
préparer correctement la date et aussi
pour voir si vous serez au rendez vous
est ce qu'on en fait une haie ce qu'on
en fait deux
est-ce que je suis obligée d'annuler
puisqu'ils affaire celle j'en sais rien
je ne sais rien du tout comment ça va se
passer ça va dépendre de vous je vais
également vous faire découvrir la
nouvelle affiche faut savoir qu'au
moment où je tourne cette vidéo elle
n'est pas encore finie donc vous allez
la voir là je peux pas voulu commenter
voilà parce que moi je n'ai pas encore
vu et dans ce spectacle il ya beaucoup
de singularité la singularité déjà c'est
vous c'est parce que vous êtes capable
de faire des choses de dingue avec votre
cerveau et vous allez en prendre
conscience durant le spectacle vous
allez vous auto étonné j'espère bien je
prendrai le temps de vous bluffer en
même temps ça durera à peu près une
heure quarante essais sous la forme d'un
spectacle d'humour comme tous les
spectacles que j'ai fait jusqu'à ce jour
je des premières parties de malade
mental je suis ravi
donc plus vous avez les liens de
réservation et tout ça dans la
description
n'hésitez pas à le faire au plus tôt
c'est ce qui permettra aussi de voir ce
qu'on peut faire encore en plus autour
de tout ça c'est un kiff ca stress et
maintenant j'ai hâte de voir ce que vous
allez en faire et j'espère que l'idée
vous plaît que ça vous fera plaisir
qu'on puisse se retrouver dans cette
grande salle à paris voilà c'est tout ce
que j'avais à dire je suis un petit peu
ému alors je vous laisse là à très
bientôt ciao alors si c'est pas encore
fait tu peux aussi s'abonner à la chaîne
simplement en cliquant sur le petit rond
que tu vois voilà juste ici c'est ce
petit rond là ça marche depuis la
tablette le téléphone c'est extrêmement
pratique il n'y a plus de raison
d'attendre
allez-y abonnez vous c'est cool